>> From the Library of
Congress, Washington, D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Good
afternoon, ladies and gentlemen,
and welcome to the African
Middle East division.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb, chief of
the division, and I'm very happy
to see you all here for the program
today, which is a discussion on how
to make a film under very
difficult circumstances.
But more about it in a moment.
As most of you already
know, our division is made
up of three sections: the
African, the Middle East,
and the Hebraic sections.
We are responsible for materials
from 78 different countries
in the Middle East,
Central Asia, the caucuses,
as well as from the entire continent
of Africa, North and South Saharan.
Our Hebraic and Judaic collections
come from all over the world.
We also serve these
materials to patrons here
and in our reading room, in our
reading room, and organize programs,
exhibits, and other activities
that highlight these collections
and that inform our
patrons about the countries
and the cultures these
publications come from.
The African section is
very active in acquiring
and developing collections, briefing
visitors coming from the countries
of the regions and the regions
for which they're responsible.
They've organized symposia,
workshops
and have an ongoing program
in partnership with a poetry
and literature center at the African
Society for the National Summit
on Africa, which is
the conversations
with African poets and writers.
And we've had some exceptional
people come and talk to us,
including Chinua Achebe
and Ali Mazrui.
We in the African and Middle East
Division are reaching out to those
who have researched and done work
on our countries of responsibility.
We ask them to share with us
their insights, their findings,
and their ongoing work so
that all of us attending
and participating can learn
more about those regions.
Today our special guest is
J.R. Biersmith who will talk
about making a documentary
in Somalia, Men in the Arena,
and about the challenges two members
of the national Somali soccer team
faced together as friends on the way
to achieving their dreams.
And to introduce Mr. Biersmith
is our own Abdulahi Ahmed,
who has been, himself, a member of
the national soccer team of Somali,
i.e. that is before he joined the
library and who continues to train
and supervise young American
Somali soccer players here
in the United States.
So, Abdulahi, will you
please introduce the speaker?
Thank you.
>> Abdulahi Ahmed: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I was a former soccer player,
but I still play on Saturdays.
Okay, so, it's a short introduction.
Men in the Arena is J.R. Biersmith's
first feature-length movie.
The three-year journey to make
the film in Somalia, Kenya,
and the United States has been
chronicled in a number of national
and international publications
including the BBC,
Sports Illustrated,
and the NPR Radio.
Prior to his work on the
film, Mr. Biersmith produced
and published content
for more than ten years
across the country,
the United States.
He started his broadcast
journalism work at the Miami Herald.
He graduated with a BA
in International Business
from Bradley University, and he
has a MA in broadcast journalism
from the University of Miami.
And we should welcome
Mr. J.R. Biersmith.
[ Applause ]
>> J.R. Biersmith:
Thank you so much.
It's great to be here.
Move this little microphone.
Can everybody hear me okay?
Okay. I came by the library
yesterday and I met Abdulahi,
and I didn't know that
you played soccer.
I learned the history of all the
research that he's been working
on in Somalia, and never
did he mention himself.
A typical Somali way.
So, I really appreciate the
invitation to come and speak today.
It's really an exceptional place.
On the way in, there's a, if you're
watching via webcast at some point,
there's a little map maybe
75 yards from me, not little,
a giant map that was made in
the 1500s that has maybe one
of the first, the first image of the
United States, or of North America,
which is kind of remarkable.
We're surrounded by all of
these books and it's just,
it's really a beautiful place.
And I want talk about
another beautiful place
that doesn't always get referred
to as a beautiful place,
and that's Somalia.
And journalists often say
for years, they've debated
about when it started,
but journalism is supposed
to be a first rough
draft of history.
And I looked at the world,
the world stage and thought
about where Somalia
fit on the world stage.
And it's been a failed
state for a long time,
it's been a troubled place that was,
in 2012, about to seem like it was
on the cusp of some
kind of comeback.
So that's where kind of my
journey and look at Somalia was,
can we look at it through
a new prism?
Can we see it through a new light?
And I thought, as a storyteller, a
documentary might be a good place
to try to write a first draft
of history about a place
that doesn't often get
looked at in that way.
So, that's why I named it
what I did, and why I wanted
to talk to you all today.
So, we'll scoot through here.
I took this image here of
Morgan, which is an elephant
that has been researched
for a very long time.
And it was in Kenya, and
recently, Morgan made some news
because he traversed across -- I
don't know if it's a he or she,
so don't, if you're a wildlife
expert, don't quote me on this,
but crossed into Somalia.
And it struck me because I -- you
very rarely think about Somalia
and wildlife, and there's
images like this that exist
and are happening every day there
that rarely find itself
inside the news.
And to talk about, you
know, a living heartbeat,
I think that's what I was
chasing as a filmmaker is,
can we get into Somalia and
find something that feels alive?
That feels like it's not death
and destruction and war and piracy
and famine and the single story.
So, in 2012, I was in
the process of moving
from New York City to Los Angeles.
And being a -- I started out my
career in finance in New York City,
and then I took a vow of poverty
to be a journalist and went
to the University of Miami.
And on the way, after a
quick stint in New York,
I went back to St. Louis and picked
up my sister's old 2006 Saturn
and made my way to Los Angeles.
And while I was in St.
Louis, I just happened
to catch a story on the radio.
And it was NPR's Fresh
Air with Terry Gross.
Maybe some of you have listened
to that show, of course.
And Michelle was talking about a
book of hers called Decade of Fear.
And while she was talking
about Decade of Fear,
Terry Gross prompted
her and said, "You know,
there was a story inside your book
about a young man from Mogadishu.
And he and three of his friends
had an encounter with Al-Shabaab
that was quite difficult
and I'd, you know,
appreciate it if you
would talk about that."
And so, Michelle jumped into
this story, and it's one of those
where you're driving down the road,
and you don't remember driving.
You just kind of remember
being captivated by something
but you got there safely.
And I remember getting to my
sister's house and taking some notes
and thinking, something
just happened.
I just heard a story about a place
that I hadn't thought
of in a long time.
And the story that she was telling
was about this young man, Ismael,
he was 16, and he was recruited
by Al-Shabaab and he said,
"I want to get an education,
I don't want to join this
proxy terrorist group."
And they took matters into their own
hands, along with three other boys,
and they took them
inside the soccer stadium
and they publicly amputated his
right hand and his left foot.
And then they came back two
weeks later and got more.
And Michelle Shephard told this
story to Terry Gross and continued
to say, "Hey, inside my book
I describe what happens."
Well, she wrote a paper,
or she wrote an article
for the Toronto Star.
She's a national security
correspondent.
And that work emboldened the Somali
diaspora that was living in Canada.
And they started a project
called Project Ismael.
And project Ismael was
a giant response to,
how do we get this young man
out of Mogadishu onto safe soil?
Like, there's no way he can
get, you know, doctor's care.
And she wrote the story.
Canada didn't take him
in, but Norway did.
And so, then she flew
back to Mogadishu --
well, actually Nairobi because
they got him out, met in Nairobi
and he ended up in the Arctic Circle
and she accompanied him there.
And as you can see
from this image here,
the top right is Ismael inside
Mogadishu, and then you can see he's
in the Arctic Circle
up in Northern Norway.
And that story really struck me.
Because it was the first time
I realized that I'd thought
about Somalia through the
eyes of a young person.
And I remember somewhere in one
of the articles that she wrote,
he mentioned wanting
to kick a soccer ball.
And I spent the next nine
months after listening
to that story in a deep dive.
It's one of those where, if you've
ever been on, you hear music
on the radio maybe, and then
you have to Wikipedia it and see
who sang that song, and then
three hours later you're
down some rabbit hole of research?
That was what happened with me for
Somalia and it took me nine months.
And there was a show on,
I don't know if you've ever seen
the Showtime show Home Front
or Homeland, rather.
And you know, she's --
Carrie, the figure in the film
or in the TV show, she's always
pegging things up to a board
and sticking them up and
getting images and trying
to get her plan together.
Well, I did the same thing.
I got a board together and I started
taking all these images of Somalia,
trying to figure out, what was
the story that I wanted to tell?
And it just so happens that FIFA had
put some AstroTurf inside the main
soccer stadium in Mogadishu.
And that story was making its
way through, you know, Twitter
and the internet and various places.
And I thought, uh-oh,
this is something.
This is the first time that
there is a turf in a lot of years
that young men can go and
women can go play soccer.
And the national soccer team
seems like it's reassembling
and it's going to try to play
in this annual tournament.
So, I put this Black
Hawk Down image here
because in this nine-month
journey of trying to make sense
of Somalia, I read a lot of books.
And one of them, of
course, was Black Hawk Down.
And the significance of it, as I
thought of a lot of the young people
of Mogadishu, and they were born
the same year that Black Hawk
Down happened in that
October of 1993.
And so, when you think about
the seminal battle and kind
of US foreign policy, the idea that
young people were being born just
down the street, and now we're
on the national soccer team
potentially really fascinated me.
Like, there was this big gap in
history, like a lost generation,
and I thought maybe this was an
opportunity to tell that story.
So, I want to play
something for you real quick,
because this will take you
inside of, I think inside
of my head a little bit, and
why listening to the foreword
of Black Hawk Down ended up being
a big therapeutic moment for me.
So, this is about a minute-thirty.
I'm going to let this
run for a second.
It's Mark Bowden introducing
the foreword
of his book, Black Hawk Down.
Oop, that didn't work.
We'll try this again.
Uh-oh. I preloaded all
this stuff, there it is.
>> The Battle of the Black
Sea, or as the Somalis call it,
Maalintii Rangers, the
Day of the Rangers,
is one that America has
preferred to forget.
The images it produced of dead
soldiers dragged by jeering mobs
through the streets of Mogadishu
are among the most horrible
and disturbing in our history, made
all the worse by the good intentions
that prompted our intervention.
There were no American reporters
in Mogadishu on October third
and fourth of 1993, but after a
week or so of frenzied attention,
the world events quickly
summoned journalists elsewhere.
President Clinton's decision,
just days after the fight,
to end Task Force Ranger's
mission to Somalia,
accomplished what he intended,
to slam the door on the episode.
In Washington, a whiff of failure is
enough to induce widespread amnesia.
There was a [inaudible]
investigation and two days
of congressional hearings
that produced the partisan report
blaming the president and Secretary
of Defense Les Aspin, who
resigned two months later.
But that was it.
I began working on this story
about two and a half years
after the battle was fought.
I've been intrigued by the
early accounts of the fight,
both as a citizen and as a writer.
But the undertaking intimidated me.
I had no military background
or sources.
Nevertheless, I remained
curious enough
to read whatever stories
I saw about the incident.
I was especially intrigued
by President Clinton's subsequent
struggles to deal with it.
>> J.R. Biersmith: So that's it.
And, I wanted to play that and
share that with you because,
first he's talking about why
he was introduced to the book.
And then he says, "I've been
a journalist for a long time,"
this is Mark Bowden speaking,
you know, inside this piece,
"and I had no foreign
correspondent experience."
Well, I was laying up, many a
nights, thinking, I don't either.
And when I heard him say that,
I suddenly felt this,
okay, I can do this.
Like, I think that, if
he did it, I can do it.
And for me, it was,
in a similar way,
akin to what Michelle Shephard's
storytelling did for me.
It kind of lit this spark of, and
why I think story is so important.
And their rough draft of history was
a link for me to say, I think I want
to try to understand a piece of the
storytelling that's going on there.
And so, when Mark Bowden said that,
and I told him personally
a few weeks ago, it really,
it emboldened me and I
felt like I can go do this.
And not too soon after,
I had touched base
with the Somali Football
Federation in Mogadishu.
Football, soccer here in the US.
And I got an email shortly after I
said, "I want to make a documentary,
and I want to do it about the
Somali national soccer team."
And I don't think he really
understood what I wanted to do.
So, I was put in the process of
putting together a big draft trying
to explain to him in basic language
why I wanted access to the team
and why I wanted to
come to Mogadishu.
Because keep in mind, very
rarely does a Western journalist,
especially in a war-torn
space like this,
want to come tell a
story about soccer.
So, I think he was a little bit
like, "Why are you doing this?
Who's paying you?
Are you the CIA?
Like, are you some kind of
counter-intelligence guy?
What's happening here?"
So, I got an email, which I have
lit on the screen here and it says,
it's from the secretary
general's assistant saying,
"My secretary general is in Tahiti
for the beach soccer world cup
as he is a member of FIFA's
beach soccer committee.
It's the first time in nearly
ten years that a member
from Somalia is doing a
FIFA work at a world event
since Farr Ado [phonetic]
was banned by FIFA."
That was a gentleman that was a part
of the Somali Football Federation.
"You can now meet him if
you interest face to face.
You can have a meeting."
So, it's a little bit of a broken
English, but that's the email I got
on a Sunday, and three days later, I
used some airline points and I flew
down to Tahiti, and I met the
soccer federation president,
and it took six days to convince him
to let me have access to the team.
And I think it was just
a bridge-building thing.
I think he just wanted to fully
understand why I wanted to do it
and what my intent was, so I just
wanted to share that picture.
And there, you see there,
Abdiqani is the Somali Football
Federation president.
So that's where it
started, and he told me
that there was a soccer
tournament starting a month later
that the Somali was
going to participate in.
Well, the Somali community
in Nairobi,
Kenya was having a
little bit of trouble.
Because there had just
been a terrorist attack
at the Nairobi mall called Westgate.
And inside the Westgate
Mall in September 2013,
a number of people were wounded
and maybe 60 or 70 were injured.
And a month later, the Somali
national team was coming to town
to Nairobi to play soccer.
So it felt kind of like,
on the world stage,
that something was happening, and
all these young boys were going
to come coalesce and
try to play some soccer.
That's where our film begins.
So, when I get there, I had
no idea who I was meeting.
I had done all of this research.
I showed you the pegboard
that I created.
I put all these faces on it,
and there was one kid that I saw
on the internet whose
information I could find
and it was this young
man named Saadiq.
And Saadiq, you could see
here, it's a picture of he
and his little brother
in Mogadishu as kids,
and then he's got the soccer ball
on his head, and another photo
that you see is my
co-producer sitting
around a table with
Saadiq and Sa'ad.
And Sa'ad is his best friend
from this small village called
Afgoye that's just outside
of Mogadishu.
And we had handed out
a questionnaire,
because we didn't know
anything about the boys,
handed out this questionnaire,
there was an English and Somali,
and Saadiq came up to me while we
had handed out the questionnaire
and said, "J.R., you know, my
friend has a really hard story
that he doesn't really feel
comfortable talking about.
I was wondering if you, if he had
to write it all on
this piece of paper."
And I said, "No, he
can tell us later.
Like, we're going to be
here all week, you know,
like for a couple weeks frankly."
And, it turns out that Sa'ad was
captured by Al-Shabaab in 2010,
and they went and they grabbed
everyone in his village.
After seven days of being captured,
he was told he was
going to be killed.
The village elders worked to get
him released, but they had gone
around all his village, told all
the people to come out and watch,
that he was going to
be publicly whipped.
And as he was trying to share
the story through Saadiq,
inside this moment, I
realized there's 20, you know,
maybe 18 kids on this team.
But something's happening here.
Like there's a kid that knows a
little bit of English that's living
in Nairobi because a lot of Somalis
get pushed out and are, you know,
there's a big Somali
community in Kenya.
But I felt like there was this
like brotherhood thing
that was happening.
This humanity thing that
I was chasing in Somalia,
seeing one young man
have a friendship
with another and look after him.
And there was, I remember vividly
that Sa'ad had beads of sweat
that were falling down his head
as he tried to recount the story
to Saadiq and then Saadiq told
my co-producer, and I was kind
of listening from afar, and
I was just taking his photo.
And so, I thought that
was maybe the first thing
that would get me a window
into this team and the humanity
and maybe something
that might be here.
And it just so turned out that Sa'ad
and Saadiq were the two best
players on the national team.
So, as the story and the weeks
would progress with this team,
that's the storyline
we ended up following.
A few more slides,
and I'll tell you,
and we'll open it up
for questioning.
Here's the thing about
Somalia, which,
when you're doing all your research,
you know, for a Mark Bowden,
he flew in the back of a cot plane.
And cot is the, you know, a leafy
substance that gets chewed on
and gives you a small little
high if you chew enough of it.
And that's how he got
into Mogadishu.
Well, I got into Mogadishu because
Michelle Shephard, the same woman
who I heard on the
radio back in 2012 --
I was nervous to contact her, but
I waited a full year, I said, "Hey,
I'm making a documentary.
I've been to Kenya.
I've spent all this
time with this team.
I need to get back to Mogadishu.
And I need to know how."
And she said, "Well,
it's complicated.
Asymmetric warfare," meaning an
attack can come from anywhere
at anytime, "has made reporting
in Mogadishu quite difficult.
Even though Al-Shabaab,
this terrorist group,
has kind of been pushed out
of the city and is on the run,
they still do targeted attacks.
So, it is, it is difficult,
but I can help you.
I can help you get back in.
And so, when you go back to
Mogadishu, you're on the ground,
and as a white Western
journalist, you have a --
or storyteller, you go in an SUV,
a blacked-out SUV, you have a truck
in front of you, and you know, four
guys sitting on the back of it,
and that's how you
navigate through the city.
And I'll show you a clip
of that in a second.
But it got to this realization of,
in the planning to go to Mogadishu,
that access to my subjects
was the biggest challenge.
And further got me pushed towards
like, I have to tell this story
because these kids can't
tell their own story.
Because if they speak out, you
know, as public soccer players,
everybody knows who they are,
if they try to speak their truth
and just talk, it's
going to get suppressed.
Or they'll become targets.
They will get attacked.
So, there was a real reluctance
when we first met them
to even say the word.
Like they wouldn't
even utter the word.
And so that was the most
difficult challenge about trying
to make a film about Somalia
was, how do you even get access
to your subjects when you have
to travel around in this car,
or you can only talk via Skype?
So, I'm going to show you how I kind
of navigated getting
access to my subjects.
This is the young man Saadiq that I
showed you, and he and I, over the,
before I went to Mogadishu,
like six to eight months later,
he and I would talk on Skype
once a week, and I was just going
to show you a quick clip of
one of our conversations.
>> Saadiq: I'm not feeling good for
football because, well, I just train
and I hope to see some
change in the future.
>> J.R. Biersmith: Okay.
Well, keep your head up.
You'll be okay.
>> Saadiq: Yeah.
>> J.R. Biersmith:
You're a good player, man.
You're young, don't forget that.
You'll get your opportunity.
>> Saadiq: I know, but, you know,
what I'm thinking is, you know,
football, I'm playing football
because I want to, you know,
to play to beat, to get better.
>> J.R. Biersmith: Mm-hmm.
>> Saadiq: That's why I'm
playing football, but you know,
people laughing at me a lot, so if
I don't get the option of football,
you know, life would be hard for me.
>> J.R. Biersmith: Yeah.
>> Saadiq: That's why I want to
change, I want to change my life.
>> J.R. Biersmith: So,
if you could tell there,
I wanted to put subtitles
on there for you,
because you probably struggled
to understand what some
of what he was saying.
There's a rule in journalism:
you don't record your subjects
without their permission.
Well, every time I
would have a Skype call
with Saadiq I would
record the conversation.
And I recorded the conversation
because I would often struggle,
I got very good at
understanding him speak, you know,
when he was speaking
and getting through.
And he knew English, It
was one of four languages
that he had taught himself
and he taught himself English
by listening soccer
games and watching clips
on YouTube while he was in Kenya.
And by the way, Saadiq was
supposed to be born in Mogadishu,
but his mother fled at the start of
the war and he was born in Kenya.
And he lived in 13 different
cities until he got noticed,
he went back to the Somalian
national soccer team when he was 16.
Had played one summer
back in Mogadishu
in 2012, right before I had come.
And he got a bunch of death
threats because he spoke
out on the radio about, "Hey, I'm,
you know, I would like for there
to be peace here so
that I can play soccer."
And he went back to Kenya, and they
picked up this really good team.
So, inside of this
conversation that I had recorded,
I realized that maybe
this was how some
of the story was going to get told.
That these conversations
that I'd had been having
with him might be my
access to subject.
And as I start building
the film I would go back
and reference these
clips all the time.
And at one point, when I did
the first cut of the film,
that was the opening scene.
And it was the opening scene,
and I, of course, built around
and put subtitles, and did all
kinds of other things to it.
But it was the opening scene
because I thought it was
Saadiq at his most vulnerable.
It was him being fully human
saying that "I want the opportunity
to change my life," which was
the thread that I had been,
the narrative thread that
I had been looking for,
which is that universality of every
kid, if given the opportunity,
would like to make
their dreams come true.
That's all something that
we all can relate to.
And so, that clip for me really
epitomizes the journey that we were
on and where we were trying to go.
And so now, before I
went back to Mogadishu,
I made a quick little video about
going in; it's about 30 seconds.
Actually, this is the one
that we had when we got there.
Let's see if it plays.
Come on. Oh, codec unavailable.
So we'll show it later.
So, what happened inside that video,
it's a drive through Mogadishu,
and it gives you a window into,
you know, what it's like to try
to have a camera in your hand, and
have blacked-out tinted windows,
and you can only shoot
through the front.
And you have pre-determined
routes where you can get out
and access your subject
and turn a camera on.
Which if you think about that,
having access to character,
how do you just roll
camera and get the moments
that feel just authentically
there for you
to try to tell a story around?
So, when we got there,
and a big piece
of the film is this place
called Mogadishu stadium.
And funny enough, inside Mark
Bowden's Black Hawk Down,
the film adaptation of it, our
American troops go running back
to what is called Mogadishu stadium.
And Abdulahi, maybe you played in
that stadium, I can't remember.
Yeah, so, Mogadishu used
to have this soccer stadium
that was the crown
jewel of the region,
of Central and Eastern Africa.
I mean, everyone wanted
to play at this place.
And it turned into the war place.
It turned into the most
strategic spot in the city to be,
and if you wanted to
control Mogadishu,
you controlled the soccer stadium.
And it was protected,
it was elevated,
and this ends up being
the war place.
It's like this symbol of, if soccer
could actually come back here --
well, while we were in Mogadishu,
an invitation was extended to some
of the soccer players to
come visit the stadium.
So, these are some images from --
Bonadir Stadium is where
the turf is, but then that,
it looks like a gun, but it's
actually an old clock tower,
and that's looking onto the
field that is now quite barren
and where our troops
went running back to.
And these are the boys.
Sa'ad, was still in Mogadishu,
that's the other young man
that I built the film around,
and then that's his friend
Ahmed in the truck with him.
And Ahmed, we had called the
day before, and said, "Hey,
Saadiq couldn't come
back to Mogadishu.
Would you like to come visit
Mogadishu Stadium with us?"
It was a, you know, a
very nice invitation from,
and we feel like a
really, a big first step
in the right direction,
getting invited back.
Because AMISOM is the military wing
that controls the peacekeeping
forces.
And they keep trying to push
back Al-Shabaab, so there's kind
of this back and forth
between peacekeeping
and they make this argument
they have to keep the stadium.
So what's striking and I
don't include in the film is
that Ahmed was terrified, because
if he's caught riding in this car
to the stadium, it has
major repercussions.
So, I edited the entire
film to keep that out,
and then you just see this
scene inside of the stadium.
And so, I think that that's
interesting only because you have
to make these editorial
choices that you don't want to,
because at every turn
we had to think
about the safety of our subjects.
So, if I can skip forward,
and hopefully this one plays,
after I was in Mogadishu and
did some filming and we caught
up with Sa'ad, we went to Mogadishu
stadium, I went back to Kenya,
and Saadiq had gotten
a tryout offer to come
to the United States
from a university.
And he had got a, he had applied
for his visa, and he equivocated it
to standing in the line at the
embassy and just waiting, you know,
to see if your number
would be called.
He said it was like soccer
because you would get a red card
or you would get a green card,
you know, like a yellow card
or a red card, and if you
got, you know, the green one,
that meant you got to go.
And he saw all these people standing
in line before him, you know,
trying to get in or trying to
get their case heard or whatever.
And you only get like a minute
or two to present your case;
they ask you a bunch of questions.
And he said the first
three people in front
of him all went and
they got red cards.
So, he was praying that he didn't
get those two ladies or the guy
or whoever it was that gave them,
and he got in the other line.
And he got a guy that knew
who his soccer team was.
And he said, "Oh, you played soccer?
You get the chance
to go to America?"
And a minute and a half
later, he was approved.
And he was going to
be coming to the US.
And when I went, he was supposed
to go back with us to Somalia,
and he didn't get to go because
his passport was hung up.
Well, we got back to DHL, and
it'd been shipped and this is kind
of a minute and a half of
him finding out that he,
he was indeed going to get to come.
Sorry, we're trying to --
I had all this pre-done
and it's actually not
working, sorry.
I had preloaded all these and
they weren't converting over,
but basically what happens is that
he drops his head and realizes
that his passport has been stamped
for a year, and that he gets to come
to the United States
for a full year.
So, then we get to America.
There he is, he's in Miami
Beach, we're recording him there,
and then the young man that you see
here is actually sitting in the back
of the room right now, that's Liban,
that's one of Saadiq's
closest friends here in the US.
And he had called me when I first
got back from Nairobi and said, "Oh,
you have clips of Saadiq
playing soccer?
He wants clips put together!"
Clips meaning, images because
they very rarely get seen on TV.
So, they put some clips together
and Liban put them all together,
sent them to Saadiq and that
video, that they put together,
was how he got to America.
Because coaches got to see like,
"Oh, there's this dynamic talent.
Maybe if we offer an invitation,
maybe he [inaudible] one
in a million chance get to come."
And that's what happened.
And so we had came up to Washington
D.C., we interviewed Liban,
and he's a central part of how
this journey really happened.
So Saadiq, after a week of being in
the US, kind of blows everyone away,
but he's not eligible
to play college soccer.
He missed too much school in Kenya.
So the coaching staff made a
quick phone call over to FC Dallas
which is a professional MLS team,
and they had an academy
down in Dallas.
And he went down there, and
of course blew everyone away,
and ran with the pro
team the very first day.
But he had to enroll in high school
because he still needed college
credit, and he really wanted to go
to school, and keep in mind
he's on a one-year visitor visa.
So, this is an image of him down
at FC Dallas inside the stadium.
And we took a selfie one day because
we went to the rodeo for fun.
I thought a rodeo might be
kind of fun for two Somali guys
that never really had
exposure to that before,
so we went to the rodeo,
threw some cowboy hats on,
and that's the selfie
that you see there.
And then, you know, the entire year
that Saadiq was down in Dallas,
we kept flying in my family; my
sister, her husband, and my mom,
grandparents all live in St. Louis,
Missouri so we'd fly him back
during, you know, Thanksgiving
and Christmas break and just to
get a sense of some kind of family,
you know, structure and, you know,
love for lack of a better word.
So that's a picture of Saadiq
with my brother-in-law.
So, when I was in Mogadishu, I knew
when we jumped inside of the --
AMISOM escorted us out
to the soccer stadium.
And when we got there, this is the
image of Sa'ad standing next to me,
Saadiq's, you know, friend.
And we're standing
inside Mogadishu stadium.
I had this acute realization
that my need to get Sa'ad
out of Mogadishu was
stronger than ever.
I knew that there was, I really
worried about his safety.
And just so I can quickly
explain that,
we got about three more
slides, by the way,
and then we'll open
it up for questions.
But Sa'ad came from
this town of Afgoye,
he had previously been captured
by Al-Shabaab and just repeating
that story in the film, if we
really wanted to use that story,
and if we really wanted
to use all the footage
and follow his storyline, I knew
that he couldn't really stay
in Mogadishu, because if he stays
in Mogadishu and the film comes out,
he doesn't have the
money to protect himself.
A lot of people that
can stay in Mogadishu --
and I don't want to misrepresent.
A lot of people are coming in the
Diaspora, coming back to Mogadishu,
making their homes there, it's a
beautiful place, but it's not secure
because of these targeted
attacks that happen all the time.
So, for the next year, we started
coming up with ideas to try
to figure out how we could
get Sa'ad out of Mogadishu.
And from a journalistic perspective
or a storytelling perspective, yeah,
it was crossing the line, you know,
I cared too much about my subjects,
but I realized that this was
our first draft, that I felt,
of human history inside of Mogadishu
with a bend towards sports.
All the archives had
been destroyed in 2010.
And so, I owed it to the
boys, I owed it to everybody,
the next generation that could
be empowered by their journey
and see people that looked
like them, talked like them,
and walked like them from their
neighborhoods, they could see them
on a big screen, or see
them on their mobile phones.
And so, we spent the next year
trying to come up with a way
to get Sa'ad out of Mogadishu.
And given the immigration crisis,
there's a line 20 years long to try
to get a meeting with
UNHCR; in fact,
they're not even taking
meetings in Kenya.
Well, Saadiq came up with
this idea that Sa'ad needed
to come visit his old
doctor back in Kenya.
And I don't even know
if there is a really --
doctor exists but Sa'ad told his
team, they bought him a ticket,
his passport had been stamped by
the Kenyan government to come visit,
because they were supposed to have
an Olympic Cup qualifying game.
You know, all the -- regionally
you play a qualifying match,
and then you try to, you
know, come out of Africa
and be represented in the Olympics.
And they had their first-round game
in Kenya, and they didn't get to go,
they went to Djibouti instead.
Well, he had 15 days
left on his passport.
So we devised this idea to get him
out of Mogadishu into Kenya legally,
then he got his passport renewed,
and we started the process of trying
to get him a meeting with UNHCR.
And he lived in Kenya, on a friend
of Saadiq's floor for eight months.
And waited very impatiently, but he
was arrested eight different times.
Eight different times just
because he was Somali,
just because he was a kid
that didn't speak the language
that was trying to figure out how to
exist and be human and play soccer
and try to adapt to a new
city while we he waited.
And this gentleman who's a
parliament member named Usef
[phonetic] had also been attacked
by Al-Shabaab and was living
in Nairobi, and he became a
huge ally and Sa'ad's, you know,
biggest asset, I would
say to figuring out,
every time he would get
arrested, how to get out.
There were just chasing
-- it was just police,
corrupted police chasing
bribe money.
So, this went on for a year,
and then Sa'ad came to the US
in March of this past year.
And he was reunited with
Saadiq in St. Louis, Missouri.
And he's doing quite well.
He's working at a pizza place,
he's making $11 an hour.
He wants to play pro soccer.
I don't know if it's
going to happen.
We've been, you know,
struggling to figure out,
you know, how you get him English.
It's the first time in his life
since he went to a little bit
of Koran school as a kid in Afgoye.
It's the first time he's been inside
a classroom and put a pen to paper.
And that in itself feels like a
pretty amazing accomplishment to me.
So, Sa'ad and Saadiq are
together in St. Louis, Missouri.
And they're now living with
my sister and her husband.
And I think it's pretty
remarkable because, one,
the St. Louis community has
really embraced both of them.
A lot of people have heard about
the story, and given, you know,
the conversation around
immigration and what it means
to have a kid that's 19, 20, and
then his friend be from Somalia,
I mean, hey, let's be honest: that
fits the terrorist profile right?
You're from Mogadishu, Somalia;
you're 19, 20, 21 years old.
You fit the profile.
You might come here
to do something bad.
They're athletes.
All of a sudden, they get looked
at through a different prism.
Here domestically.
They were on the front page of
the St. Louis Post Dispatch.
They're going out to the
St. Louis soccer park,
and kids can't get enough of them.
They show them how to do little
African dances before they do
their warm-ups.
And all of a sudden, you have a
little bit of infusion of culture
that you never dreamed of finding
its way into St. Louis, Missouri
and into kids' lives
that I never expected
that they would touch in that way.
And so, our journey to
make Men in the Arena,
which is a Teddy Roosevelt speech
that was given at the Sorbonne
in 1910 that talked about
being engaged in democracy,
and it's the critic -- it's not the
critic who counts, but it's the man
in the arena, It's the people that
are in there, giving their blood,
sweat, and tears, simply
participating.
And that's what the Somali national
soccer team represented for me,
was a bunch of young people with
impossible stories committing
to their national soccer team
and bringing all kinds of pride
to a country that just
eats up soccer.
Coming out to games any way
they can to see them play.
And then Sa'ad and Saadiq kind
of taking this huge sacrifice
to share their story, and
now they're in America.
And it'll be a good six or seven
years before they could ever dream
of going back home.
But only because of technology
were we able to make this film,
and only because of technology
are they able to communicate
with their families and not feel
as lonely as they would've if,
maybe when you came over and you
probably have to get that phone card
and make that super difficult
phone call once every two weeks.
So now they can Whatsapp
and talk to their families
on a pretty consistent basis.
That doesn't mean it's not hard.
They have lots of days where the
trauma brings itself back up,
where they miss home.
But I think their journey
is really beautiful,
and I think that's why I talk about
this being a first rough draft
of Somali history, because I think
they're emblematic of what it means
to be a young person
chasing your dreams inside
of a super complicated world.
So, I'll end with what I hope is
the trailer if it actually plays.
End of slideshow.
Okay, well, you can find the
trailer at MenInTheArena.com.
I would love to show it to you.
Maybe if we just take a second.
Yeah, I could.
I could do that.
That's a good idea.
So I'll bring up the trailer for
you real quick just so you can,
you've had all this back-story
now, and it's weird to be able
to not let you see
the film first, right?
You know, I think if
you'd seen the film,
you'd probably have more questions
about individual storylines,
but the reason that it's so fun
to share all this back-story is
because, when you do get a chance
to check out Somalian material.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes, if YouTube works.
Okay. Men in the, and now if I
could type, that would be great.
The Arena.
It says "full movie"; I hope
it hasn't been pirated already.
Whoa! Okay.
So, let me make this
full-screen for you.
I'm glad you're here.
Alright. So here we go.
>> For the last 20 years, Somalia
has built a solid reputation
as the world's most failed
state, a base for pirates
and radicalism [inaudible]
now aligned with Al-Qaeda.
It is one of the key security
nightmares for the world.
[ Music ]
>> If the world gave up on you,
would you give up on yourself?
If all you knew was war,
could you survive on hope?
If you got the chance to
make your dreams come true,
would you be ready?
[ Music ]
>> Wow! I used to see
it in the movies.
Now it's real!
>> I was, and so was my friend.
>> Somalia, hoo!
>> Things are way, way
different here than there.
[ Music ]
>> J.R. Biersmith: So that's it.
Thanks for the idea.
That worked out good.
So that's a little window
into, you know, the back-story
of how we made Men in the Arena.
And I hope the next time you hear
the word Somalia, maybe Sa'ad
or Saadiq's image is what
pops into your head first
versus all the other images that
we see, because there's no doubt
that there's brilliant
journalism that's going on
and people risking their
lives to tell stories
in super complicated places.
And I don't want to say
that that's not happening.
But at the same time, there's young
people all over the place trying
to figure out how to chase
dreams like Sa'ad and Saadiq.
And if we think about what
bullying looks like, you know,
if the whole world looks to
you in a light that feels
like fear, what does that mean?
There's social media now.
That's how these kids communicate.
They know how the world
looks at them.
How do you take that on?
They have passports that can't
be, it's a license to go nowhere.
Like they literally cannot travel.
No one's going to take
a Somali passport.
They can maybe go to Turkey, maybe.
So, Sa'ad and Saadiq, for me, and
I hope for a lot of other people,
and an entire generation
back in Somalia represent
that if you do the best that
you can with the situation
that you're given, you never know
when your shot to get your dream
to come true will happen.
And I think the fact that they
chose education, they chose to try
to play soccer, I hope
that that empowers a bunch
of young people back in Mogadishu
and, frankly, who are Somalis
and immigrants and anybody that's
trying to chase their dreams
in different parts of the world.
So, any questions?
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah, of course.
[ Applause ]
>> I'll ask the first question.
>> J.R. Biersmith: Sure.
>> What about their families?
Their parents?
Did you have to contact
their parents?
>> J.R. Biersmith: Do you know
that the young lady
behind you is not happy
that you asked the first question?
Because she's the woman in the room.
Say again about their families.
What was the question?
>> Were they aware of the movie?
Were they involved
with making the movie?
>> J.R. Biersmith: Yeah, so both
of -- yeah, Sa'ad and Saadiq,
both Sa'ad and Saadiq, both of
their mothers are in the film.
I didn't interview the mothers.
I hired folks in Mogadishu to
do those interviews for me.
When we went out to Sa'ad's
village to interview his mother,
I wanted to do it myself,
but I couldn't.
Because of Sa'ad's prominence and
being from this small village,
if a cameraman goes
with him to his village,
and you look like I
do, he stands out.
It's like, "Oh, what are
those guys doing here?
What's the story they're
trying to tell?"
So, we sent a guy that had
worked for Reuters from Nairobi,
he went out to Sa'ad's village and
got the interview with his mother.
And there's a really powerful moment
in the film where she talks about --
he was born in 1993, five
months before Black Hawk Down.
And it was just coming
off of the famine in 1992,
and so she was pregnant
during that time.
And she said she'd go to the river
water, the Shebelle River to,
just to get drink, you
know, to get anything
and she had nothing to feed him.
So, like she couldn't
even produce breastmilk.
So, to think about just being
born and surviving is, to me,
is a statement in itself.
And now to think he's
in St. Louis trying
to navigate this complicated world,
complicated society that we live in,
and that's what I think is
so, you know, I'm going more,
I'm expanding more on your question,
but I get excited about his journey,
because I'm learning a lot as well.
Like I've learned a lot about my
trajectory as an American citizen
and what I expect from the world
because they're in my presence.
And when they're around you,
you get this sense of simplicity
and what matters, you know.
And we make these busy schedules.
And Sa'ad, for the life of him,
cannot figure out why
everyone's so busy.
Like just why are you running around
all the time and so much stress
and now you got these bills coming
from all these different places
and -- you know, and
that complexity.
Or Saadiq will say, "There's
a woman at the bus stop.
Like why -- and it's raining.
Why didn't anybody pick her up?"
We just drive, you know, like
we don't think about it anymore
like it's a feared thing.
We don't just pick somebody up
and set them in the car anymore.
That doesn't happen.
So how they challenge me to see
the community that I grew up in
as a result of these mothers
that somehow got them raised
and on their own two feet
is pretty remarkable to me.
Of course, I've worried
about both of their safety,
both of the mothers, like anybody
that appears in the film I worry
about on some small level.
But I think, Sa'ad and
Saadiq were the, you know,
they're the central
figures of the film.
And they've both said that, and
this one is what breaks my heart,
is that, you know, "Both of our
moms, like their journey was
to raise us, and I
hope that they're okay,
but they did what they
were supposed to do.
Like, they raised us."
Like, that's what they're
most proud of.
And I don't know how to take that.
I don't know what that means.
Other than, we hope
that they're okay.
And certainly, I do too.
So, yes?
>> Well, I just wanted to
say thank you very much.
>> J.R. Biersmith: Thank you.
>> And about two years ago, in
2014, you showed Scoring for Peace,
which was a film about
the people in East Africa,
Burundi, [inaudible] and Uganda.
And so the filmmaker donated
the film to the library,
and we hope that we'll
get Men in the Arena, too.
But I also have a question,
and that is,
as a journalist myself,
I know that doesn't pay.
How did you fund this?
All the travel --
>> J.R. Biersmith: Oh,
that's a good question.
I left all of that out.
That whole part, all that struggle.
I did, I worked on a project
when I first moved to LA,
and then I got to, I did a lot
of, when that project was over
and I went to Tahiti, I spent
that next six months kind of just
on surviving on the
money that I had saved.
And then I did a bunch of freelance,
like some random freelance
projects just
to get some supplemental
income, and --
but this has really been
my life for three years.
And it's been my life because
it's so incredibly complicated.
I mean, in the middle of
night, you're calling Ethiopia,
asking for footage of one game.
Like I wasn't even sure if I
was going to use it in the film,
and I had to track down a
journalist, figure out how
to get a hold of the guy that might
have the footage that, you know,
holds it, you know, for the
dictatorship that's in charge
of media that like chooses to
license things, so the journey
of trying to make this was just that
every single turn felt impossible.
And that's why I extended way
longer than I ever expected.
So after I went to Somalia,
we did a Kickstarter campaign,
and we got $39,000 on
the Kickstarter campaign.
That was tough.
Like I thought I'd just send some
social media emails around, like,
"Hey, if you like what
we're doing, give us $10."
You know? Nobody was giving $10.
Like, they were sharing
it like crazy, like,
"Oh, this is super moving!"
But nobody was giving money.
Like I thought it would
just roll, but it didn't.
Like it didn't just roll.
I made a lot of phone calls,
and thankfully to my sister,
my brother-in-law, they started
calling friends and saying,
"Are you in for this amount?"
and all of a sudden,
you know, weeks went by,
and we got that money
that we needed.
And that helped a little bit,
but just going to Somalia
for the five days that I was there,
not to mention the countless other
filming trips that we did there,
was like $10,000 just
for that five days.
Because it's extremely expensive
to go out into the field
because you have to have all these
security teams and everything else.
So that's how, and I borrowed a
lot of money; I owe a lot of money.
That's the short answer
to the question.
I just never, I just never dreamed
that it'd take as long as it did.
And I think some people would say,
"Well, why did it take so long?"
Well, it took so long because
we spent a year trying to figure
out like, literally every single
night trying to figure out,
what do I do now to get
this kid out of Mogadishu?
And that's not a, like
a heroic thing.
That's like being human.
Seriously, like when you meet these
kids, and you talk to these kids,
and you hear, like, the
sacrifice that they're making,
you don't have another choice.
Like, it feels like your kid.
You know? Like I got to
make sure that he's safe.
And so you just don't stop
until you get that done.
And so, that's the long answer
to, how do you figure out how
to survive making a film like this?
But now we hope to distribute it,
and, you know, it should be released
in April, and you know, hopefully
it gets picked up by some networks
and it'll be on Amazon,
iTunes, etc. But you know,
and as far as donating it to the
library, I said it's a first draft
of history, that's how I look at
it, and this place is the epitome
of taking care of rough drafts and
original drafts and original prints.
So hopefully it finds its way here.
>> And then it's a copyright issue.
In other words, when you --
>> J.R. Biersmith: Right,
do we license the coverage?
We sent that in a few weeks
ago, so if somebody would
like to approve that,
that would be great.
[Inaudible] Yeah, it's
like $20, right?
>> Exactly.
>> J.R. Biersmith: Yeah, we applied.
We're just waiting on the response.
>> For the copyright?
>> For the copyright.
[ Inaudible ]
>> J.R. Biersmith:
I've already applied.
[Inaudible] Yeah, so
we went down that road.
Yeah. Yeah.
[Inaudible] I would like to.
It's funny because this one
just, there's a part of me that,
because I'm so buried and
mired in the weeds on this one,
that the journey that you don't
see on film is interesting for me
from a chronicling perspective is
I'd really like to write a book,
and that's going to require
picking up some of Sa'ad
and Saadiq's story and even Liban.
I mean, if I can just say -- Liban's
sitting at the back of the room,
so I hope you stick around for a
second, and I know you're not going
to want to do this, I'm
speaking directly to him.
But you know, Liban was, I'm not
going to give your whole life story,
but what he does for his
family is unbelievable.
And he would call me nearly
every other day on his break,
if not every day, because I
would say, "Hey, I need to talk
to this person; I need
help with translation."
And he would take his
15-minute breaks at Home Depot,
or his lunch hour, and we would
call people in Somalia, Ethiopia,
wherever, and he was like,
my guy, he did everything
for me for a year and a half.
And I think that's
really remarkable.
Like that's like, talk
about selflessness.
I mean, all he did was call
me one day and say, "J.R.,
can I get Saadiq's clips?"
And then, three years later, he's
been, you know, he's almost been
like a father figure to Sa'ad
and Saadiq too along the way.
I mean, not only just
a friend, but you know,
a real source of, how
do I handle this?
And I think, his journey, and
now he's driving Uber cars
and doing whatever he can, but he
really wants to do cyber security
and he's just waiting for
his passport to come in.
And I just think that, like,
I didn't do this alone.
You know? I didn't write this, I
didn't do this, and my co-producer,
myself, Liban, like, we did this
because terrorism can find its way
in your backyard at
any point in time.
And unless you start
to try to understand
or go at it a different way --
like everyone's trying
to approach Somalia
and these failed states
in a war way.
What if we approach it
with a storytelling way?
I'm not naive enough to think
it's going to change everything,
but what if people have
heroes to look up to
and that's why I think that,
I'd like to write a book.
But making another
film, it's kind of,
maybe I should do something lighter?
Like maybe something a
little, I'm fascinated by Cuba;
it's just which story
do I want to tell?
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Well, first
of all, thank you very much.
It was a very moving and
very inspiring story.
>> J.R. Biersmith: Thank you.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: I
wanted to ask you something.
You know, sometimes tragedy is
overwhelming, and you had to focus
on something that you as
an individual can help.
What is it, what was it about those
two young men, what was the quality
that you saw in those two
young men that made you say,
"I'm going to help them"?
They'll be able [inaudible]
accomplish their dreams
with some help [inaudible]?
>> J.R. Biersmith: Yeah.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Why those
two, and not, you know --
>> J.R. Biersmith: The other kids.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb; Other kids?
What is it that you saw [inaudible]
that you were able to identify,
because they actually lived
up to what you were expecting?
>> J.R. Biersmith: Yeah,
I mean, I think that's why
that clip is interesting
that I showed you.
Well, it's interesting for me
because I feel like I'm a bit
of a motivator on a personal level,
and I've been that for Saadiq.
You know, so in moments where
he gets really sad, you know,
and feels like the world's against
him and he can't, doesn't know what
to do -- not to mention, like, his
best friend tried to leave Nairobi
on a boat and died at sea
right before he came to the US.
So, the tragedy that he
continuously has to face --
the first day that I met him, he
called himself the grandfather,
a grandfather because at 17,
he had already seen enough
that he gave himself
that, you know, "J.R.,
my grandfather hadn't
seen that much stuff."
So, There's something about him.
There's something about,
like, his energy when he,
I mean, Liban can speak to it.
There's something about it's
tucked away; he's really shy.
He doesn't really like, I mean, he's
going to come out here tomorrow,
and he was hesitant about it.
He gets, you know, he's just
like, "I've told my story now.
Do I have to talk more?"
You know? But every time I,
he'll participate in a Q and A,
he'll say something
that just blows me away.
I'll give you an example, and I'll
try to make this really quick.
We were at a screening and
somebody raised their hand,
and they were from Britain or
something, somewhere in Europe.
And they said, "Hey, how about
that team that just won in Europe?
They weren't expected.
And they had that great guy, and
they weren't, they were supposed
to be like at the bottom
of the premier league,
and they won the whole thing!
What'd you think of that?"
And I'm like, and I was thinking,
"How's he going to answer this?"
You know, because he
loved that team,
he was so surprised that they won.
And he said, "You know,
that's a great question,
because that team reminds
me of Somalia.
Like, they were from the
bottom, and they were just there.
And then they were trying to, it's
like what we were trying to do
when we went to the tournament.
Like we just wanted to show up
and give everything we had."
And I'm like, "How
did you just do that?
Like, that was a PR spin.
Like you just brought the
question back to you."
And so that's what he does,
like he has that subtlety,
but that doesn't mean that
he's still not a 19-year-old
that doesn't struggle
to make his way,
he's a college kid making
his way through the world.
But I think that's what it was, and
it was really that first night too,
of when I saw the bead of sweat.
And that's what I'm chasing,
like I'm chasing moments
that aren't just moments.
Like moments that reveal
real character
that show you exactly
who that person is.
And through that first two
weeks that we were with both
of those boys, we got these
moments that, if somebody shows you
who they are, believe
them, and I believed them.
And it was a leap of faith,
because along the way,
there's just societal
things that are different.
And I think that, there's
been like a teaching process,
and that's why I'm so proud of
the St. Louis community even,
of trying to wrap their
heads around the story,
because now it's a
village type thing.
You know, people are coming and
offering them rides, you know,
different people, my co-producer
and his girlfriend were just
in St. Louis two weeks
ago, and they're like, "Oh,
Sa'ad has a stick-shift car
that he doesn't know how
to drive; it's a used car."
And so, they took him out driving.
You know, so, there's all these
people that are stepping in now
to help get them acclimated
because what they represent
is bigger than themselves.
And so that's, I hope that's
what your question was,
but that's kind of what I saw.
And I did, it was a leap of faith.
But you can spend two weeks with
somebody, and you wake them up out
of their beds every morning,
you get it, you get it.
Any other questions?
>> Abdulahi Ahmed: Well,
thank you, J.R., for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> J.R. Biersmith: Thanks again.
I appreciate it.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.